from the guy who butchered resident evil
comes the story of a town that was
butchered by a volcano
I think there's method to the madness do
you look at it the pairing makes sense
Pompeii so Pompeii is the story of a
town Pompeii Pompeii use Roman times and
the volcano went off and just
eradicated Pompeii is pretty much Roman
Atlantis with a volcano pretty much it
and like the shitty movie Pearl Harbor
the act itself that we paid popcorn
money to see only lasts a little bit so
you got to fill in everything that
happens before the disastrous event with
the big forced romance that you just
don't care about in which case we have
Jon Snow from Game of Thrones his entire
family was wiped out by Kiefer
Sutherland who plays the dick in this
movie then he kind of Falls for baby
doll from sucker punch disclaimer those
are not their real names except for
Kiefer Jon Snow's a gladiator he's
lower-class he has fallen for this girl
who's upper-class in the disaster
strikes and I gotta hope to survive it's
pretty much like that one movie in which
you have the guy who's lower-class he
falls for the girl who's upper-class and
disaster strikes and they gotta hope to
survive it differences Pompeii's done by
a director who's not as good as James
Cameron look when the was going
down that was all fine and dandy volcano
goes off you're like yeah fireballs in
that there are cool scenes within the
movie the tsunamis scene was hands-down
the best scene in the movie that was
cool the volcanic stuff cool the problem
is the characters before that we're
supposed to care about them and you
don't our main character is the strong
brooding gladiator type it doesn't say
much he's a man of very few words which
is a very good support character but
when the main characters that you don't
care as much about him you're like I'm
not attached to you I hope you get
killed and swallowed by the volcano and
your little girlfriend to the best
character in this movie the one I
actually did care about hands down was
I'm gonna call him mr. Eko from lost
because his name is that and I can't
pronounce that it's very tough people
have a hard time pronouncing John's
properly ads John's it's not Jan's
if you've ever pronounced my name
improperly imagine pronouncing he's mr.
Eko from lost and he was awesome I liked
him uses big brute but he had honor he
and Jon Snow become friends too like
brother but the rest of the movie we
come on a gladiator out for revenge
because of this dick who killed his
family two lovers who
actually lovers because they've known
each other for about 10 minutes in the
movie seriously in terms of face time
they don't have much more than 10
minutes together they got a survive
disaster we've seen all the elements in
this movie before and we've seen it done
better because initially I saw a trailer
to Pompeii oh holy the story of
Pompeii that's awesome then I was like
wait a minute
if you look at it it's just a disaster
movie it's all it is which granted again
Titanic is a disaster movie but again it
had character and you see the slow swell
of chaos it's a survival instinct that
starts overtaking the entire crew the
ship that was cool and this one the act
is it's a volcano that is sort of
sinking ship it's all good dude oh
credits yeah volcano goes good and
mankind kind of knows where they stand
in this town so some of the disastrous
in Pompeii was pretty cool in that
guilty-pleasure kind of way like in that
2012 kind of way we were like yeah I
mean that was entertaining to watch but
am I gonna go out of my way to watch it
now in the end I will say Pompeii is
probably a fun time if you're drunk yeah
and now it's a party holy let the
boring part end all right oh my god the
volcano went off awesome I feel bad
because when I say a movie's a good time
if you're drunk that by implication
means if you guys do listen to me if
you're a beige and responsible of course
you have a designated driver who is
watching this movie sober so to the
designated drivers out there I salute
you thank you for keeping your friends
safe I owe you there's a Pompeii have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you